i am councillor brynn herron and i'm
chair in the meeting today
i just want to first remind you of some
of the domestic arrangements please
please ensure that microwaves
microphones
are turned off we're not in use
i'm put off by lavinia's eating
obviously aren't i
that you do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt
you may be asked to leave and can you
please
ensure that all your mobile phones are
on silent or switched off
i'd like to remind everybody present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
being repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where
there are confidential items
if you make a represent representation
to the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to be
infilmed by entering this meeting as a
speaker
you were also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public impressed are not
lawfully excluded
now just have a roll call of the
officers i think we've got jon snell
here
melissa evans jen robinson is not and i
think emily you're covering
for her um and as well as
emily there's sue palmer
and that completes all the offices is
that correct
i've got a picture of henriette in front
of me i'm not sure if you're there
um or not henriette good afternoon
uh council hearn um i'm just sort of
monitoring and and dipping in out of the
meeting to see if anybody needs help so
i'm here but i'm not having any part in
the meeting ah that's lovely henry
i thought maybe that's what you're doing
welcome aboard and good afternoon
um i'll move to the agenda now um
and we'll start off with apologies we
have apologies
from councillor mike norris and also
from
james castin and lavinia hadingham your
um
your deputize and i believe
uh do i have any declarations of
pecuniary or non-pecuniary interests
by members are there any to declare
no item
three that's the minutes of the previous
meeting from about two weeks ago um
they're due out next week so they're not
um they're not ready today but i've
already spoken to mandy and
they will be sent round hopefully early
next week
item four petitions do we have any
petitions
mandy no no petitions
any questions by the public no questions
and questions by councillors none
received
okay thank you will no move to gender
item number seven
please that's on page five
of your papers and i think john you're
going to present this and
run us through it before we go to
questions and debate
so over to you john and very welcome
thank you chair and good afternoon
members
um the report that you have in front of
you details the
council's significant risks as of july
2020 and the work undertaken around risk
management processes since
april 2019 and normally this is a
an annual report and you might have
expected to see the risks as of
the 31st of march but bearing in mind
that we're we're into
august it seemed to very sensible to
actually provide an update as of july
rather than something that was
historical
in terms of our approach both councils
are clear that the responsibility for
managing risk
belongs to everyone and therefore
there needs to be an appropriate level
of understanding of the nature of risk
this approach is actually supported by
the approved risk management strategy
as part of good governance the councils
manage and maintain a register of the
significant risks
which you'll find are linked to its
priorities and regularly reviewed by the
senior leadership team
and regularly reported that both
cabinets and annually as i said to
this committee to provide some clarity
to those members new to risk management
i thought it would be helpful just to
provide an overview in the process
and hopefully you'll find this useful so
the slt
hold quarterly workshops or have
certainly been holding quarterly
workshops
um prior certainly to curve 19
where the significant risk register is
reviewed in terms of its risk
scoring and mitigation potential
and emerging new risks are also
discussed
each risk on the risk register is owned
by a member of slt
and following each workshop session they
will liaise with their representative
cabinet lead member to ensure they're up
to date with the risk position
from the report or dependency you'll see
that there are currently 18
risks on the register of which 11 risks
story of which risks 11 and 15 have been
separated to reflect the different
levels of scoring between the two
councils
in summary 10 risks have been scored as
medium five have been scored as high
and five have been scored as very high
on the register itself you'll see that
each risk tells a story
across the page starting from the
initial inherent scoring that's before
any mitigation
is applied through to the current
position and ending with a target score
and outstanding actions to help achieve
this score
now i'll probably appreciate those who
have actually spent some time looking at
the register that
some of the plan completion dates will
need to be revised
um that's not to say that they haven't
been completed because i know some of
those actions have been completed
um but they will remain on the register
in terms of how we monitor and manages
their risk but clearly
some of those completion dates need to
be just updated and i'll go back to the
relevant
risk owners to have that in place for
you
during the review of the register a
number of risks
were de-escalated to an operational
level
where they will be monitored at a
corporate level corporate manager level
this will be an ongoing exercise and
should reduce the number of risks
on the significant risk to a more
manageable number
these registers continue to be updated
and discussed between the corporate
managers and their assistant
directors they will also discuss any
potential risks that may
need to be escalated to the significant
risk register
the report also details those risks
deemed to be top risks
facing the councils at this point in
time
these risks may not be the highest risk
scored on the register
but are those who considered a high
priority by members of the senior
leadership team
in terms of the other work that we do as
a team the audit and risk management
services
staff continue to work with report
authors offering guidance and assistance
when capturing and reporting and
recording the appropriate risks
and scores to both committees and
cabinet reports
once reviewed these reports are signed
off before submission to ensure that the
correct use of wording
of risk from the scorings are correctly
applied
although not mentioned in this report
there is a move to integrate
performance risk and finance reports
together
to present it to cabinet on a quarterly
basis and i'm working with my
counterparts to ensure how we actually
do that
and correlate those two or those three
disciplines together
i'm happy to take any questions at this
stage on the report counselors
[Applause]
okay thank you very much john i'll move
to questions in a moment on a
um alphabetical order probably just a
question for me john to sort of settle
in my own mind um
there's different sorts of risks isn't
that there's financial risks there's
risks of
not performing risks of not doing what
you say
and embarrassing risks i just wondered
how you rate these different criteria
against each other
the approach that we've adopted
counsellor is more of a holistic
approach so
you're quite right there are financial
and non-financial risks and these are
assessed
on their own merits and they're
aggregated together
so we would then come up with a risk
scoring in terms of the likelihood and
impact but you're quite right each of
those elements in terms of management
concerns as well
also things that are going to be
happening tomorrow that we're aware of
and also that horizon scanning as well
so each of those elements would be taken
into account when we established that
there is a risk that needs that's deemed
to be of significant importance to put
on that register
and then we would actually take those
different elements score them and come
up with a collective score in terms of
the
likelihood and impact okay yes that very
much helps
explain it um okay i'll go to questions
now and then at the end when i've been
through
everybody i'll um i'll open it up for
any extra questions or any debate uh
first on the
list is oliver emmerson um i'm not too
sure if you're here
you're here are you one of them i don't
believe councillor american is in the
meeting
no i haven't seen him come up on my
screen
um lavini you're next in james caston's
place any points or questions to ask
just to just a quick one it might be a
bit of a you know
nonsense one the the risks john that are
sort of um
point 12 and above are they are sort of
covered related because of you know
who knows about the future you know the
ones you know i can say the ones that
are very high
is that to do with you know frankly the
crisis we're in right now or what
um certainly those top five risks that i
sort of mentioned
um two of those six uh 17 and 18 are
covered related so we had the initial
lockdown through covid in march and then
potentially risk 18 is looking at a
potential second spike or a second wave
and we just how we going to be geared up
to to address that should that actually
happen
it's not quite as a big as risk as you
might think because we've already got
things in place in terms of looking at
our critical services making sure that
staff are redeployed
so we have sufficient resources to
maintain those critical services
but nevertheless it is obviously
something that's high on our agenda and
we need to be very mindful of
but i was just thinking with things like
the gateway 14 thing that must be
affected you know
filling that and everything that's
that's going to have a knock-on effect
isn't it
yeah i mean certainly coded 19 across
all our services there's going to be an
element of impact
um and that's dependent on terms of the
services providing
and obviously it's down to those
corporate managers and assistant
directors then to assess
what changes and processes resources
they actually need but yes you're quite
right that code of 19
sadly has an impact right across the
board in terms of our service delivery
okay thank you okay thank you lavinia
i'm not too sure if melanie has joined
the meeting
i think possibly not maybe from now on
mandy if
um either oliver or melanie turn up you
could just let me know
otherwise we're gonna have to assume
they're not here i think yes i will do
uh councillor robert lindsay um question
from you please
if you have one that is sure yeah um
well i uh i don't know it's a
question or a comment or but there's no
um that the next item is looking at our
treasury management and i see we have
investments in you know very
via schroders four million quid there i
presume that's in um
kind of stock market assets we've also
got
investments in um in the pension fund
that's managed by suffolk county council
pension committee
that both of those areas expose us to
the risk of
um fossil fuel assets becoming stranded
we've seen bp just cut its dividend um
uh oil companies are now operating in an
oversupply market with demand for oil
having collapsed i just wonder if that
should be
on our risk register given the
both the investments in the treasury
management
and through the pension fund
okay john that's a bit of a googly for
you are they investing in the wrong
things
i think is where this question is coming
from yeah i'm not an expert in those
um financial institutions but i would
imagine unless somebody's going to
correct me
and feel free to chip in melissa but i'd
imagine
they have their own strict
regulations or processes and procedures
to try and remain climate friendly as
possible because i don't think it would
do
their interests particularly good um
should they not
be but i it's a bit of a different one
because i don't know what
they have in place uh in terms
of moving forward and trying to to
obviously become sort of carbon neutral
as we are trying to do um
but i don't know as i said i can't
really comment in terms of
what their policies and procedures are
within those financial institutions but
i would imagine there is something
around
climate change and how to address that
i'm not sure that probably answers your
question
um with could i just come back
chair yeah just yeah with with
schroeder's
um they're obviously what's to stop us
just asking them
what their policy is and if they haven't
got one
can they please get one um well i
presume we're paying them to manage our
um our money and so
they ought to be able to i have asked
the question before
and i was given the answer that how much
of the
the we've got four million across baby
and mid-suffolk
with schroders so two million each
apparently
nine percent i seem to recall of that is
in fossil fuel
companies um so
um you know the way to mitigate the risk
would be to get schroders to
um to give us a a fund that
doesn't invest in fossil fuel stocks
john before you answer um melissa is i'm
jumping up and down would you like to
come in melissa and join this part of
the debate
thank you chair yes um i can certainly
say that uh schroeder to
all the companies uh that we invest in
they are very proactive in the
uh environmental and social governance
arena and we are a very small part of
that
investment fund so our voice is is very
small but
i certainly take on board your comments
and we have got a meeting with arlen
close later in the week actually
and that's one of the things that's top
of my agenda to discuss with them is
you know what can we do to get some
assurances around you know the fossil
fuels and
and what are all the attempt you know
alternative investments as well
and so that's one that's that's there's
top on my agenda to talk to them on
thursday
so thank you okay thanks listen i've got
john madison next but i've also got dave
um
wishing to join in on this particular
topic dave do you wish to come in
yeah i've actually got no questions at
the time because john actually did
actually answer the question that i was
going to ask regarding the completion
dates on the risk register but
uh we did discuss that our pre-meeting
yesterday and
i'm happy to hear that they will be
updated a new report issued with those
dates on so i'm happy with that
thank you okay that's fine thank you
very much
um john it's your turn to speak now yes
thank you
and before i ask my question
i appreciate if mandy could give me a a
ring off
off off camera so to speak uh after i've
asked this because i keep
losing the um the papers for the meeting
which is very inconvenient
but um yeah the the question
really was the and john's has sent me a
link now but the
the the operational risks that have been
de-escalated or or
never actually become um you know the
primary
significance um
they used to be relatively easily
available through connect
with that um that sort of honeycomb tile
business um and i know there was one or
two problems where i
asked questions and and it and the chief
executive got a bit
crossed because um departments hadn't
keep think
have been keeping things up to date um
but now that seems to have disappeared
altogether and um so
i wanted to ask that we make
the operational risk of registers
relatively easily available to members
should they wish to look at them so
that's my
question at the moment if we could
improve on that
yes thank you councillor um hopefully
you found the link was okay and you
managed to to get into
those um tabs at the bottom of the
the registers which would have then
provided you with a list of those
operational risks of service level
delivery um
so we could we can sort of tidy that up
as well one thing i did want to add
just to perhaps reassure councillor
matheson is that
when obviously risk from a significant
register are de-escalated they should
find their way on the operational risk
registers
unless there's a very good reason why
the risk has been totally terminated and
we can control it
but in terms of the process
what's being introduced is as part of
the
assistant directors one-to-one with
their corporate managers
there will be a standing agenda item on
risk operational risks
so those operational risks will be
addressed and obviously
um the corporate manager will be
accountable uh for those risks and
uh if they're not updated then obviously
um we'll have to provide an explanation
why why they haven't been i know in the
past that council methods and i've had
long discussions about
particularly the operational risk
registers and the onus is very much
obviously on the corporate managers to
um to keep them updated um but also now
that the assistant directors will uh
have that as a zed as a standing agenda
item to
to raise that very question and about
the risks
and whether those risks are still
pertinent whether they need to be
escalated up
or actually just taken off the register
but obviously with full explanations to
provide that audit trail
yeah yeah that's that's that's helpful
thank you
but i think the you know really part of
my
my question and my issue is you know can
we
you know can we actually get it seems to
have been a deterioration
of information being available to
members
um you know the concept of sort of
drilling down um
through through layers of information
and and
contacts and so forth for departments
that seems to got appreciably um worse
than it was say
say a year or two years ago um
okay it's a some prospect of getting it
to a better place
uh well certainly council i i will try
certainly i mean
not really that much has changed from
last year
because i know that we've had long
conversations and uh certainly i've
hopefully have tidied that up but
they remain on connect they haven't been
moved from connect so they've always
been
on connect so hopefully you know access
to
to those from not just members but
officers as well other officers
it should be fairly easy but i mean
certainly i'll have a look at that for
you and see whether there's any ways
that we can
perhaps improve that availability for
you yeah
well maybe what i actually actually need
is help from mandy to find out why i'm
not actually seeing the connect screen
but that's we can take that later on um
yeah if man it could give me a ring or
something i'd be much
um appreciating thanks sorry councillor
matheson um henriette will actually give
you a call oh right
good thank you okay thank you john
i'm sure that can be put right um
councillor alastair mcgraw i'm tending
to use official sort of titles to start
with and then dropping into christian
names as it's
probably easier for me but alistair you
have a question
uh yes bryn just a couple of things uh
looking through appendix a which lists
the full tables of the various risks
facing both councils
um i'm just noticing noting the the
various risks that
we have the greatest of these seems to
be
and they're not unrelated to each other
covid19 and uh
financial outcomes uh for the future of
both councils
those two stick out but obviously they
are um
well they're not immediately under our
control until we've got through this
crisis
what i wanted to ask john though was
what would you say how would you
characterize the overall trend
in risk management in the course of the
last say
year uh because this report more or less
covers that year
how would you characterize the the
approach
yeah thank you it's very good question
uh councillor in terms
of where we are now um perhaps uh as
opposed to perhaps a year
or even more ago um i think it's fair to
say that in terms of risk management um
it's deemed to be a bit of an
administrative burden uh for
for many of us not just this council but
for many councils up and down
the land um but i think certainly
as we've heightened awareness in terms
of
how we provide our services in the best
most efficient and effective way
i think we've become far more aware of
the
the boundaries that we work in and the
constraints that we work in and
therefore i think in terms of
how we've moved forward risk management
i think there's a greater understanding
from top to bottom
so in terms of taking how you know risk
so seriously
um what we've done in the past we we do
it subconsciously but we're not we
haven't been particularly good at
actually um articulating it down on
paper
so we think risk all the time if you
think about how we've got here
you know what we're going to be that the
problems the it issues so
instinctively we're always thinking
about risk that we haven't always been
good at actually to say recording it
i think we're in a far better place now
and i think that's down to
certainly from senior management who
take risks extremely
seriously and that's descended right
down to even junior members of staff
we've also had experts and i have to
professor though
um risk management force under my
umbrella i wouldn't say that i'm a risk
management expert
i apply in the trade of being an
internal auditor
so i have a a fairly hopefully good
understanding of
risks and likelihood and impacts but to
supplement that in the past what we've
had we've had actually a professional
that's come in and given several
presentations to slt just to get us
really started and thinking more
corporately and how we're going to
manage these risks
but not not just now but as i said about
horizon scanning what's coming around
the corner that we need to be aware of
so i think in terms of our approach it's
far more proactive
than it has been in in the past uh which
is extremely good
and you know and testament to councils
like councillor matheson who's uh
who i'd like to say politely has been on
my case for many years
but in a very positive way in terms of
how we've pushed and moved
risk management to the forefront so i
think you know when we look at
the way we've developed our risk
register if you go back again a year it
wasn't really telling a story
from start to finish i think the current
register when you look at it from the
right to the left
it actually provides that level of
detail and understanding
and they'll say the final call is around
about you know what further action do we
need to be
and what is our target now some so what
we're aiming for is how can we mitigate
further those risks and reduce so
there's a greater understanding of where
we need
to be and that no it's not just a
significant risk register but also that
disseminates down to the operational
risks
um and also that the amount of work that
not just myself but the audit team has
undertaken to support um
not just members because we provided uh
presentations to members
but also to our staff as well so i think
we're in a much better
uh position in terms of understanding
we've still got improvements to make
we're not perfect
but i think in terms of where we are
supported by the risk management
strategy
when we're looking at our risk appetite
i think we're in a much healthier
position
in terms of understanding and reacting
in a very positive way
can i just follow up on that please yeah
please do alistair far
away i i recall some discussions held
some years ago
on a scrutiny approach to risk
management
and and assessing risk and it does seem
that there's a great deal more
systematic approach which i think is
what we
we asked for at the time from a scrutiny
point of view
and it does it does appear that that's
actually bearing fruit now
that's just a comment but thanks very
much
okay thank you alistair um councillor
mary mclaren
uh thank you have a question please i do
i have a question for john um i was
interested
in risk 13 which is about health and
safety
of staff and what the risks were
and considering that uh
working has changed dramatically for the
majority of
council staff are you considering a risk
that might be associated with
uh working at home or working in
isolation from
teens thank you
yeah thank you council that's a a really
good question
it's actually it doesn't just apply to
officers it members as well
so i know that arthur um is
acutely aware as is hr of the health and
well-being of our staff because
really with any organization that's the
the main asset of any organization is
the health and well-being without that
then an organization is likely to fail
so that's taken extremely
importantly in terms of health and
well-being there's lots of support
networks as well
both in within the organization and
externally if we're feeling pressured
it's down to senior management the
corporate managers and particularly to
make sure that the health and well-being
of each other
so for example not wishing to embarrass
melissa we
this is part of a little group that we
have that we just touch
base once a week to make sure that we
are okay
uh and basically sound off our
frustrations to want of a better thing
but generally i think um it's down to
to management to make sure that our
staff all well
particularly on our one-to-one so uh
there should be one
monthly one-to-ones that go on with our
staff that gives
us an indication it's not there are
flaws in this and i'm the first to admit
that
um talking as we are now doesn't
necessarily give you the right picture
you know i i'm a bit of a traditionalist
i like to see the whites of people i
advise so but we don't have that luxury
at the moment but
um it is important to touch base with
our members of staff
regularly we also have elt the extended
leisure team and often that is on the
agenda in terms of the health and
well-being of staff
so we're acutely aware of that and we
can't afford
for obviously staff to feel particularly
unwell
in these very difficult times i mean
interestingly
in terms of sickness records we have
very
very low sickness records which in some
ways is a little bit surprising
but i think in fairness to the testament
and resilience of staff they've been
coping extremely well
and hopefully with the relationship that
they have with members of staff and
colleagues
that would be flagged up if people were
struggling
so we are conscious of looking after one
another
so i think it's a valid value point and
i think that we are in the right
position to
try and capture any sort of concerns
that we may have
so can i just ask will we see on the
risk register then john at later date
in terms of a a unique risk a separate
risk
that's something that i can have
discussions with catherine steele who's
responsible for
um obviously like payroll um health
um and personnel so that's something i
can speak to
suzanne as well uh the corporate manager
there so
we can have those discussions where we
feel we can
manage it at an operational level or
whether there needs to be an escalation
onto the significant risk register i
think if we found that
we were creaking badly in terms of
people going off sick
and having health problems then i think
you're absolutely right
that it should be at the moment the
indications are
that it's being well managed and
therefore we would expect to see it
managed at an operational level
but but certainly i can have those
discussions
thank you john yes thank you john i
think um
mary's almost asking for a sort of a
health audit just to check that nobody's
um
dropping off the radar and that might be
good and just before i bring in emily i
think i can say as a counselor i did
really appreciate a call earlier on from
claire
asking if i was alive well insane and
i was able to reassure on at least two
of those things so um
and i hope the other councillors had the
same call and being checked on
emily you've got your hand up um you
wish to comment on this
yeah thank you chair um i just really
wanted to build on
the information that that john has
provided in his
uh response there is a significant risk
um that's on the register that relates
to overall sort of
health and well-being of the staff so
that's a kind of catch-all
um specifically with regard to to covert
19 health and safety and wellbeing
we've undertaken a number of health and
safety questionnaires
with staff members about working from
home and making sure that they've got
adequate arrangements at home so that
they've got a safe working environment
we're also undertaking health and safety
risk assessments for
staff members who are coming back into
the office
for various um essential activities so
if they they're needing to go to
endeavour house to conduct a meeting for
example as we've got staff members doing
this afternoon
then they do have a risk assessment
around that and then alongside that we
also have
uh some specific well-being activities
relating to covert 19
so we've run some workshops for staff
about
sort of personal resilience and managing
workloads managing stress managing
multiple
uh conflicting priorities with sort of
managing your home life and child care
and other things that this period has
thrown at us so
um just really to provide reassurance to
the committee that
there is a whole suite of activities
that have been going on to support um
staff throughout throughout the pandemic
and the changes to the ways of working
and i think that probably demonstrates
why it doesn't need to be escalated onto
the significant
risk register as a standalone because
we're doing so many of those mitigating
actions at the moment
thanks chair thank you emily that's very
very helpful
um i can see john you've got your john
matthew your hand raised can i just
leave you bring in dave muller and i'll
make you first on the roundup at the end
uh councillor dave miller do you have
comment or question please
i think you haven't got your microphone
open um dave
but i did lip read you and you said
i'm sure you said no comment um john
matherson would you like um you've got
your hand up for a supplementary
uh yeah yeah well i um i had
these we'll be on questions are we
discussing the risks now
a little more you're first off so you
you can carry on with that theme
okay well the um taking particularly you
know john's points about coving and so
on that the
um a number of the the dates
and the the even some of the risks
we need reassessing very urgently i did
wonder whether we should actually put
the risk register back on our
agenda um in um a lot less than 12
months time actually
but on these specific risks um
there was this discussion we had in with
um
tom barker in the opposition briefing
um last week um
the the joint local plan it's it seems
clear that there's a very specific risk
which has been created by the government
publishing a white paper on the planning
system and and the the risk is
that we if we don't get
the joint local plan um i think it's
called regulation 19
version um into the government's hands
for an inspector um be
before before the uh
some kind of of um guillotines going to
come down
we would then have to start again
basically under
a different set of rules so there's a
very
specific risk there
which which is is i think rather than
the the general
um point about further action is to
continue to develop the joint local plan
it's very specific now i think
we have to get it we have to get it in
ahead of that
government timetable not that we know
what the timetable is but
um there's the risk you understand the
risk john
yes i think um yeah thank you for that
john and before i go to the other john
um i think it's something we're all
aware of we have set out a timetable
are you asking that it be speeded up and
we do it before i think that's the um
the nub of your question is that correct
john i think i
i think the it's just there is a very
clear and specific
risk which needs to be identified which
is you know it's
very fundamental um because we know how
much trouble
we get into if we haven't got an
up-to-date local plan
and we know what happens if the system
changes halfway or some of us do anyway
that we're around in about 2 000 and um
or something when we had to start
rewriting
uh and i think that was that's what led
to the the um what's it called the the
um
the focus review of the core course
strategy focused review
um heaven help us um was because
we they changed the system when we were
halfway through doing the doing our
local plan the previous
previous one so that i just wanted to
recognize that absolutely
um the um
apart from that i mean there's several
like you know four five and six where
where the um the mitigation is not going
to be possible
because of covid and john's accepted
that that um
that they're they're gonna have to um
change unfortunately
um i'll have a look through my notes
i've got one or two others but someone
else would like to have a go
okay john um i'm not too sh i think what
john matherson's asking for is almost a
policy change um
john snell are you able to answer um
john's fears
um and correct me if i'm wrong i might
be looking almost at emily to reassure
but i think when assurance is given when
that paper
was presented to cabinet members
in terms of the time frame i thought
there was general concern in terms of
whether we were going to meet deadlines
but i thought assurances were given on
the day
when that paper was presented
yeah well i wasn't at the cabinet but
but
obviously similar assurances were given
to the opposition briefing
but what i'm saying is is the the
assurances
are good but they need writing down
under the further action comment
of risk one yes thank you john
as i see it as a councillor it was
debated at full council and a
very firm title timetable has been
agreed emily can you confirm that
uh yeah so um chair just to confirm
obviously the news of the planning white
paper has
been very recent so um i think probably
the best course of action is for us to
take
those comments uh from councillor
matheson away and
speak to to the ad for um sustainable
communities and and establish whether
that significant risk needs
updating in light of that that new white
paper and particularly in respect of the
timetable for the local plan i think
that's probably the best
uh solution rather than john or i trying
to uh
advise you on on the local plan i i
wasn't looking for that at all just the
recognition of the risk i think that's
what we
we're here for really okay john well
point well made and um
point taken um aleister you wished us
we're we're in the general free-for-all
now so if anyone's got any
comments on things that are actually um
on this agenda
item please just um i could i could see
you all but aleister far away
it was just to follow up on john's um
john matherson's comments on the
planning system the white paper i recall
makes specific reference to joint local
or local plans
that are at stage 19 um and gives a
specific time frame so it's just a
matter of marrying up the
time frame in the white paper and the
time frame that we already have in plan
i just throw that in because i think
that's my recollection of what i've read
yeah yeah and sticking to it oh yes i
take your point john
yes we would all hope that are there any
further questions um
on this agenda item from um from the
committee
you've still got your hand up john now
you've gone there any further questions
i think if i can just say john john
snell i think going back to my first
question if hey you judge risk um
i read through the paper very well i was
just interested to know um
how highly you scored the risks i think
like 3.94
i'm not meeting the um carbon targets is
a
massive um political risk of and
something we need to do or even earlier
and was further down the paper i picked
up that um you regardless has been at
risk of not
appointing another sort of pr person
when i think we have um
six already now i might regard that as
um
not even a risk something that perhaps
we didn't ought to be doing anyway in
this financial station and
situation and there's so many things
like that so that was
the reason i just want an overall
picture john of how you
scored risk and if something um like the
second thing i mentioned
was avoidable is there a chance of
taking it back to
um policy and changing a mind on that
one because
we do need to save money as well don't
we
yeah yeah absolutely cancer i mean
obviously it's a very crucial risk hence
why it's obviously found its way onto
the significant risk register and i know
that um the ad responsible is taking
that very seriously so
um and it's something that's sort of
cascading down
and if i can provide any assurances that
interestingly i've got that in the
internal audit plan for this year
so i've agreed with cassandra clements
the ad
that we will do an overview of where we
are
at some point during the year as well so
just sort of
perhaps give members that assurance how
sort of serious we take this particular
risk this is a risk that's on there but
it's obviously a risk of how we actually
mitigate it to
prevent us falling into not becoming
carbon neutral by 2030
so that will be a watching brief and as
i said
this register is regularly updated from
slt's point of view so if there's any
developments obviously that will find
its way
in terms of the mitigations and actions
that taking place
and as i said at some point during this
financial year we'll be undertaking an
independent audit
on where we are as a position statement
thank you john henry just bringing you
in you're looking to speak
no i'm afraid not have i got a hand
raised i hope not
exactly there's a big yellow hand right
across your picture but um
robert you're looking to speak yes
thank you chair um two two questions
um one just on that carbon
risk one um the original motion was
also about an ambition no it's used
quite fuzzy language but for for carbon
emissions across the whole
of suffolk so across the community the
wider community
not just the council so i don't that
we seem to have just from the wording
orbit
of the risk it seems to be just focused
on the council's own emissions but
i don't know whether it's perhaps john
can explain why
why we haven't looked at the wider
community there um and the other
question was um
risk 15 um
what's that all about um is that to do
with um
merger it says new way of delivering
services or something
i'm not clear what what we're talking
about there but it says it's all been
put on hold by kovid anyway
but and and for some reason they were
more at risk from that than
than mid suffolk so it's just a bit of
an explanation of numbers 15 please
yeah i might um pass it over to my
learning colleague
um emily yule who's the risk owner
uh in terms of risk 15. um
coming back to your earlier point
councillor um
obviously in terms of our ambition and
looking at
the wider community um perhaps i can
then take that point up with perhaps the
the assistant director
if you wish
yes please thank you yeah
[Music]
emily i think you're going to comment on
this
yester in terms of risk 15 um
it is related to uh potential
structures of the council and the the
potential benefits that those kind of
structures might have
in terms of the financial stability of
the council so um you'll see that the
the risk is around um the the financial
security of the councils
or the the um the risk and then the
cause is
is looking at different delivery models
and obviously part of that is increasing
working together
and the potential savings that could
arise from
from those joint working operations
thank you emily
john you've got your hand up john
madison um
you have a last question thank you yeah
um
yeah it's at risk eight nine really our
our room
our asset investments um
the i have to say that that
i mean i know the these the residues are
just you know
i know john actually did say i i was
struck by that it did just say that it's
regular regularly updated and
um i i just i wonder a little bit on
gateway 14 risk nine um
it seemed to me that the the further
action that's listed
um of i think effectively find
finding a partner to
to who with with the ability to to move
the project forward
um that that had been done
but the and that really the the the
mitigation of risk
now ought to be talking more about
marketing
um the development of potential
development
um so that that one kind of looked out
of date really
my understanding of where we're up to
with it because we did put through
um was it council in february
an agreement as to who the development
partner was
that might have been a confidential item
but i don't think discussing the fact
that we
discussed it is is it breaches anything
really
um but also on cifco risk gate and
the the the likelihood that we meet the
income
projections um over the next
uh six six months or twelve um
is now vanishingly small unfortunately
and um so i think that risk ought to
reflect that um because it's a problem
that
isn't just covered related
it's actually structurally
embedded and has has
been made worse by kovid so i
i think those two those two particularly
worry me
as to you know how we're describing the
risk
at the moment and and what the what the
mitigation
needs to be i mean the mitigation is
always
rather subjective well we're going to do
this and it will
it will reduce the likelihood of x
happening
um is inevitably
um i say it is subjective and so i think
we have to look hard
at those and particularly that's why i'm
i'm looking
to make them you know more specific like
the what i'd have said about on risk
number one
to be as specific as possible makes it
easier to see
that we're achieving it and therefore
it's justifiable to
to to to reduce the likelihood of the
whatever risk it is
occurring because there are a lot of
quite um red
items on here and um yeah
okay so i think that that's the other i
think those are the other comments
i really wanted to um
to make uh yeah
thank you okay john thank you i'm jon
snell can you reassure us on
any of those please yeah certainly those
two risks that casa matherson has just
raised i can go back to
uh emily a tech assistant director
responsible for that area and have a
word with her in terms of looking at the
risk descriptions if you like and
perhaps using that as a way forward to
update those risks and the mitigations
that are in place particularly with the
current climate as you said that we are
facing
okay thank you john um dave you've got a
hand raised
yes i'd like to congratulate john on
this excellent report
and i would actually move that would
like to move the recommendation in
paragraph 2.1
that the content of this report
supported by appendices a
and b been noted thank you chair
yes thank you very much dave do i have a
second for that
yeah i'm happy to second that um brynn
thank you that's slovenia thank you very
much live and lavinia just before i go
to the vote i see we have um
councillor john whitehead in the meeting
um you're obviously suffering john from
the lack of football going on
um is there anything that you wish to
comment on what you've heard so far
um can you hear me yes we can hear you
well i'm welcome
thank you well i just really enjoyed the
meeting as an observer but i would say
that i think risk nine is
is quite well out of date because the as
you say the development partner's been
approved i think um and a new a new
hybrid
uh planning application needs to go in
which obviously is a risk factor
so i think that does need quite
extensive updating
i was also a bit surprised that on risk
12
reputational damage etc it seems to be
assigned to the assets and investment
cabinet member which sort of i'm not
quite sure why that would be
some main observations i know so my
other observation is that
i know councilman was saying that the
income projection for
sifko against plan you know it's under
threat because
we haven't invested our full amount yet
so obviously that does need to
progressing
okay thank you john and thank you for
your input um
jon snell could you um could
could you just reassure um councillor
whitehead
yeah it goes back to obviously the
previous comments so yes i can speak to
the relevant ads
i'm coming back to risk 12. um obviously
the risk owner is
the chief executive in terms of
reputation um
as opposed to yeah but i understand yes
cabinet members for
assets and uh yeah investments yeah i'm
not quite sure whether that
um in terms of the lead whether that's
the right
lead but i suppose it has to sit
somewhere but i expect that that was
what they thought was most appropriate
at the time
okay thank you john i think we should
move to the vote now this has been
proposed by councillor dave mueller and
seconded by
um councillor livett lavinia hadingham i
think mandy is going to do a roll call
now of um
approval for noting so over to you mandy
yes chair thank you so councillors if
you could reply for
against or abstain um
councillor hiron i'm four
councillor hadingham four
councillor lindsay four
councillor mccrore
having issues
is that four against or abstain
councillor mccrory
i'm four but i cannot get through to you
all right thank you
loud and clear thank you oh you got that
yes we can hear you
my apologies councillor mclaren for
councillor matheson four
thank you chair that's unanimous thank
you very much
mandy and thank you councillors um we'll
now move to item
eight on the agenda the treasury
management out turn for 1920
and that will be you melissa to
introduce i would think
i'm actually going to be uh sue this
afternoon chair thank you
oh sorry i'm sorry sir i'm stealing your
thunder come on in please
thank you chair i've got you on my
screen now thank you
loud and clear thank you very much chair
this is the treasury management report
covering the position for the out turn
for the financial year 2019-20
it provides details of the performance
effects of decisions taken during that
period
and confirms compliance with the
council's treasury management policy
the report explains in more detail the
factors affecting the strategy and
activities including
the regulatory framework the economic
conditions
interest rate and liquidity risk towards
the end of the year
the spread of the coronavirus began to
change life as we knew it
coveted 19 which had first appeared in
china in december 2019
started spreading across the globe
causing plummeting sentiment
and falls in financial markets not seen
since the global financial crisis
interest rates which had remained steady
during the year
at 0.75 percent were reduced by
the bank of england to 0.25 in march
and then swiftly reduced again to a low
a record low of 0.1 percent
at that time the uk government
introduced a number of measures to help
businesses
and households impacted by a series of
ever tightening social restrictions
culminating in pretty much the entire
lockdown of the uk
more specifically for our two councils
regarding banking activities baber
operated within the daily bank account
limits
however mid suffolk exceeded it on one
day
by 129 thousand
this was as a result of a high value
payment being received too late in the
day to be able to invest it
each council has increased its
short-term debt baba by 9.5
million at mid suffolk by 6.4 million
this was to take advantage of lower
interest rates
following the increase in the public
works loan board rates
each council lent a further 4.1 million
to sifko
mid suffolk lent a further 4.7 million
to gateway 14.
all investment activities undertaken
were in accordance with the approved
counterparty list
the council's investment activities
including average rates of return can be
found at appendix c
of the report both councils made another
investment of two million pounds each
in a higher yielding strategic pool fund
which was with investec diversified
income fund
investment by both councils in funding
circle has reduced
as unallocated funds have been reclaimed
and existing loans repaid
for baber this was two hundred and
sixteen thousand of the four hundred and
thirty thousand previously invested
and for mid suffolk it was two hundred
and eight thousand of the 423
000 invested leaving the balances at the
31st of march
is 214 000 for baber and 215
000 for mid suffolk both councils are
compliant with the upper limits for
interest rate
exposure the investment activity
undertaken for the year was done so in
priority
order of security and liquidity over
yield
as dis as prescribed in the treasury
management strategy
members should note that in the
recommendations
recommendation 3.3 relating to the
mid-suffolk
it should read that the treasury
management activity
for 2019 20 was in accordance with the
approved
treasury management strategy and not
2018-19 as it says in the report
so if you have any questions we'll be
happy to uh to answer them
thank you chair okay thank you very much
sir
well this has been my bedtime reading
for um
quite a long while now in the previous
one i don't really think
i understand it and i don't really think
i have any questions
um we'll assume that councillors emerson
and um
barrett aren't in the meeting so lavinia
i'll start with you do you have a
question on
on these papers um not at the moment no
i'm
fairly baffled too but you know i'm not
at the moment
no i'll take you in order um robert
lindsay
um well obviously i'm i made a comment
about
um the the um
is can i can i perhaps i can ask are
they
i'm aware that schroeder's is uh
invested in sort of stock market shares
what are the other funds are they
because some of them seem to be property
some seem to be
[Music]
what what is the actual assets that
they're investing in these different
buyers are you able to answer that too
uh yes the ccla is a
property fund um so that's in various
types of property
the others um the ubs
and schroders and
investec they're generally in
equities and shares and cash
and various or types so they they are
diversified within the fund to obviously
spread the risk within
each of the funds um
and obviously as the council invests in
these different
funds themselves you know we as the
council are trying to
diversify our own investments as well
okay thank you yes so i mean just really
to reiterate the point
i was just looking up how many councils
had declared a climate emergency
and it's now 67 of the 400 or so
um district unitarian county councils
across england or wales
um 67 percent of them have declared a
crime an emergency so
you know we're entitled to all all of
these
those 67 percent of councils ought to be
asking
and i assume most of them have the same
providers the same three names you know
more or less
schroders ups and just like you know
what you're doing about the risk of
climate
of um stranded assets because
you know 10 so i imagine the nine
percent
applies not applies to the all
the the total of money that we have in
ubs schroeder's investor
9 is in fossil fuel stocks i think
robert you're saying as we've declared a
climate emergency we should only invest
in green companies is that the number of
your question
uh i think um i think yes
not that we should well we wish i don't
know about we should only depends how to
find a green company
but i don't think which i think it's
incumbent on us to
examine where we're putting our money
and if we're putting it in
in um in companies like shale and bp
we're actually actively
promoting um the extraction of fossil
fuels which
which is totally against what we're
trying to do okay well i thought that's
where we're leading melissa can you help
us on this please
um yeah i i just wanted to say um
obviously when we took out most of these
investments we hadn't announced the
uh climate change and certainly the
other thing we need to bear in mind as
well is the money we have invested we
don't want to lose
with the market conditions as they are
at the moment obviously
they're not at the levels when we
invested them um so i think we'd be
foolish to sell those assets now because
we'd lose an awful lot of money but
it certainly is as i said high on my
agenda but i just need to safeguard
the council's money to make sure that we
you know we don't lose an awful lot of
money by
a quick reaction to you know to try and
get us to that place
that assures you thanks melissa i
presume some of these things are fixed
investment is that correct we
we do have that i'm sorry yeah we can
hear you
no we can't
melissa can you unmute my mute button
yeah you're fine it's on off on off
yeah now we can hear you later clear far
away please um
no we do have the ability to to sell
them as and when but as i say we do just
need to keep an eye on on those values
so
yeah i think if councillor lindsay and
matheson have anything to do with it we
will be keeping an eye on all of this
yeah john matheson you're due to speak
next come on far away
thank you yes um yeah what i i was
just looking at the um page 31
um the the debt the
mid-suffolk debt increase um to
um to public works loan board
six point four that one yeah yeah yes
it's parallel 4.6 i'm in a lot of
trouble with the papers but as you know
but
no you're in the right place john go on
yeah what i'd
well looking at those two items the the
um
that's sithko gogo 14 um
the the understanding of
the um the pacifico investment um
we when we buy a property um
90 of it is a loan from
the councils to sifco but 10
of it is is an equity investment and
what i was wondering is
whereabouts in the treasury
paper here does it show that the other
10
how does that work sure i think that's
one for you
yes um actually within
um the appendix c on page 46
of the report
um in paragraphs 2.5
to 2.
11. it sort of refers to
first of all the equity 2.5
paragraph 2.5 it refers to the equity
within
the the holding company and then
it mentions um in the next paragraph the
proportion or the
of the new growth companies and then in
2.7 it mentions the
this the equity value of these of
investment in cifco
yeah so that's the that's the that's the
cash
that's the additional cash going in when
we die another property
that's right that's the sort of the ten
percent equity proportion yeah
as a whole yeah yeah i can't i mean i
can't get the papers to work really
um what appendix did you say it was um
it's appendix
uh c and it's paragraphs
yes depending c yeah okay
thank you i'll um i'll look at that
later
okay well if you come back you've
probably got about five minutes john
um alistair mcgraw any comment to make
on this
any questions
alistair are you there are you hearing
us
i'm having the same difficulty i'm
having the same difficulty counselor
haron as
everybody else there's a slight delay in
response no i don't
nothing at the moment we can hear you
loud and clear um mary mclaren
no comments chair dave muller
no comments thank you chair you're all
happy with everything
okay there's no other hands um
raised i just wondered um sue
on page 46 just where we were any
comments on the borum gate um
center and how that's going i know it's
not completely full but um
and they're fairly up-to-date figures
but anything you could reassure us with
on on that area
i think i'll defer to melissa on this
occasion i can see melissa waving come
in melissa thank you chair hopefully you
can hear me when you button yourself
um we will be uh bringing the quarter
one uh performance
general fund performance report uh
through to cabinet
uh next month so or yeah next later this
month even um so we will be updating the
boron gate position
as a as a part of that report as well so
that will be featured in there
yes i was aware of that so um that does
need keeping an eye on thank you melissa
for um
coming back on that one um any other is
okay it's free for all now any other
debates or comments to make
on this paper please
you've yeah dave uh yes thank you chair
uh i'm happy to actually move the
recommendations in three point one three
point two and three point three chair
thank you okay thank you dave and i'm
quite happy to second the same haven't
um
gone through it pretty um thoroughly
john john snell you're
looking to speak
no you've got a hand up no not me nope
alice yeah some of the pictures on my
screen
one is superimposed on the other a
little bit difficult to tell but
alastair you've got
um you're waving at me to speak yeah
it's just uh the i think it's the muggy
weather it's delaying all our response
times
uh i mean i'm in a mixture of sunshine
with showers
uh no generally speaking i think the
report
at least shows that we've we've followed
our treasury management structures
um we're within the boundaries that
we've set ourselves
and yes there are a lot of issues about
investment and treasury management the
great thing of course is here is that
the money is being actively managed on a
day-to-day basis and it's going to be a
flexible process this isn't uh something
that's going to
change overnight on the queries and
questions over
investment in uh equities in particular
and the relationship
those equities have with fossil fuels
i believe it's quite likely the market
itself is going to change
anyway and that many of the investing
funds
will be looking for opportunities for
diversifying their portfolios
in very much the direction that robert
and john have have suggested
i suspect that's the way the world is
going uh in fact when you've got a major
company like bp talking about
not only cutting their dividend but also
cutting their own
uh exploration and extraction by 50
and and spending a lot more time i
appreciate it's not everything
but it's set definitely a large step in
the right direction
i believe the financial markets are
likely to follow that and by definition
anybody investing in those financial
markets throughout
through whatever medium is going to have
more options to to move exactly as as
was hoped
yes i fully fully support this report
yes alistair i fully agree i think it
will be self-regulating away
in this side of the world anyway um in
the eastern side
who knows um money money rules
and we will be driven by what's um
financially best to do
emily um you are definitely waving at me
you wish to comment
yeah thanks chair it's just a procedural
point um
you've got a split recommendation here
so there's different recommendations for
each council
so you actually need a baby member
to propose and another member to second
3.1 and 3.2
and then for baby councillors to vote on
those two recommendations
and then mid suffolk members for 3.1 and
3.3
please chair so um
dave if you'd like to find a seconder
for the mid suffix part
i'm happy to second that and that was
lavinia that's lovely thank you lavinia
and i'm happy to second or propose for
councillor haran
that will be fine so we've got that
sorted out pretty quick mandy would you
like to do the role
sorry emily can you just confirm if i
have to do two different votes
i think so
you vote on three point one and three
sorry is was the delay there can you
hear me now counselor i can
yeah um so so baby members will only be
able to vote on 3.1 and 3.2
and mid suffolk members only on 3.1 and
3.3
so two separate votes please mandy okay
thank you
so we'll do the votes on 3.1 and 3.3
so that will be for mid-suffolk members
only
so councillor hadingham four
councillor matheson
and councillor muller four
okay that's unanimous and on
3.1 and 3.2 for baber
uh councillor haran yes for
councillor lindsay for
councillor mccraw four councillor
mclaren
oh that's unanimous as well
thank you very much mandy and thank you
councillors
i'm now moving on to item nine on the
agenda
uh consultation on the new model code of
conduct
i'm very interested in paper and um
emily yield to present i believe
it's all yours emily yeah thank you
chair um can you hear me i've lost my uh
my you're fine buttons on my screen so
i'm oh yeah
it's fine we can hear you and we can lip
read pretty well as well so far away
perfect so i'm pleased to present the
report jac
1925 which seeks the committee's
agreement
to a response to the local government
association's consultation
on a new model code of conduct for
elected members
the background to the consultation is
contained within the report
however i would like to bring two points
in particular to councillor's attention
firstly the lga's proposals to amend the
model code
are limited to changes that can be
implemented within the existing
legislation
which is why not all of the committee on
standards in public lives
recommendations have been included
there is no intention at this time to
seek legislative change
secondly once a new model code is
published by the lga
the councils will have the option
whether to adopt it as its own local
code of conduct
and that will be a full council decision
so
any uh any change to our code of conduct
will have to go through the full council
process
the councils could choose not to change
the existing local code
or could produce a new local code which
incorporates some of the key
recommendations
however the intention is to continue to
have a suffolk wide local code of
conduct which would be adopted by the
county districts and borough and town
and parish councils across suffolk
which has many benefits uh not least
that as a monitoring officer i'm also
responsible for
town and parish council conduct issues
and it makes it much easier if we're
using the same code of conduct
so i'd now ask chair for any comments or
amendments
from the committee on any of the draft
consultation responses contained at
appendix c of the report
thank you emily i'm just to clear my own
mind
emily on 3.2 i presume that all the
councils um
have to vote to agree to do this for us
to do it suffolk wide is that correct
so in terms of the consultation
responses
each council is responding individually
but when it comes to a point
of looking at a new code
we would work together across the board
with the towns and parishes also to try
and achieve
everybody adopting the same local code
um so so that would be the process so
consultation responses are individual
all be it the the monitoring officers
from the districts and the county have
all
been in conversation but actually
looking at a new code would be
a county-wide approach
okay thanks emily and just on 3.4 could
you explain emily please the last bullet
point it says the criminal offenses
relating to
um disclosable pecuniary interests
should be abolished i don't quite
understand that
yeah so this was a recommendation by the
committee on standards
in public life at the moment
if a councillor fails to declare a
disclosable pecuniary interest
and participate in
a decision then
that's potentially a criminal offence
which is um
liable to um fines and potentially
um prison a prison sentence
um so the the committee are basically
looking to remove the criminal nature of
that
um of that element
so who would this person be answerable
to if it's not criminal offence
who then will deal with them so it would
fall to the
monitoring officer to deal with as a
code of conduct issue
okay i think you've been cut off in um
mid-thread emily yeah i lost i lost you
all i had green screen for a moment then
uh yeah so they're looking to remove the
criminal um
element and it would it would just fall
to the monitoring officer to deal with
it as with any other
code of conduct issue um so you know
under the regime fairly limited
sanctions
well i wish you luck with that i do
rather tend to think it's a bit of a
step backwards
but i'll leave it to the floor to see
how other people think
um thank you um emily very much
uh let me think same order again any um
any comments lavinia um no i think i
think it's um it all looks great
you know and so um no i've got no
further comments to make thank you
and the personal gifts have gone up from
25
to 50. that's something else that is up
for debate
robert lindsay
yes thank you chair um yes i
agree with the comments about
the bringing the council into
distributes
uh claws i i think that's
that could cover anything um and
is too broad and and it's
you know you know could could
it it's not specific enough i think i
don't think it needs to be there
given all the other all the other things
uh are enough are sufficient
to bring something in like that you know
something i say john ward might view as
bringing the council into just
distribute
i might view it as telling the public
what's going on
you know and and vice versa
so it becomes a political argument
um but we all know what what
civil behavior and good conduct is
we don't we don't we all have a
different view about what
what brings a council into distributing
okay robert i'll come back to emily
maybe in a moment um john matheson any
overall comments on the paper
yeah i kind of um having having actually
been
subjected to the processes i i somewhat
agree with robert
um that um a long a long and
and time-wasting and expensive process
of um seeking to demonstrate
um that i was bringing the council into
disrepute
um ended without um
succeeding improving that and um
so i i i've got some pretty mixed
feelings about that one as well
i think that what is very interesting is
the decriminalization though
the point the point about that
you see is that the and emily will
confirm this
that if if something falls within the
criminal
um sphere then then the monitoring
officer will not
investigate it and and so
you might you might feel that that it
was retrograde step
uh decriminalizing it but on the other
hand
the the odds of getting the police to
investigate something
um are not great and probably
prohibiting the
monitoring officer investigating them uh
is
is unfortunate so um
i think that's that is
probably on balance better to be
decriminalized or like i would imagine
that
the criminal law ultimately if you've
done something bad enough
in terms of advantaging
your your nearest and dearest or
whatever
um then that it probably even if it was
you know it was a code of conduct issue
it would become a criminal offence as
well perhaps and that memory might
comment on that can i just raise a point
of order
chair i'll stay yes yes
and it is i think it's because i would
like to emily to be able to answer this
question
as i understand it from her preamble uh
the committee on standards in public
life and their recommendations
is not what we are discussing we are
discussing the response that emily has
provided
for the council because i have
reservations about some of the
suggestions of the committee on public
law and standards in public life for
example this uh
rather woolly phrase there which says
that a councillor must not participate
in a discussion
or vote in a matter to be considered a
meeting if they have an in
any interest whether registered or not
well i'd hope most chancellors would
have an interest in what they're talking
about
and then the paragraph the sentence
afterwards which qualifies it
is very woolly it's very subjective
would reasonably regard
if a member of the public with knowledge
of the relevant facts would reasonably
regard the interest
so significant is likely to prejudice
your consideration
or decision making in relation to that
matter i mean and that just seems to me
to be
all over the place capable of multiple
interpretations
but that's not what we're discussing is
it emily
yeah thanks councilman mccraw um yeah
you're right um as i said in the
preamble the the recommendations by the
local government association are not
looking to
implement anything that would require
legislative change
so at the moment the categories of local
pecuniary
local non-pecuniary and pecuniary
interests
are contained within the localism act um
so that actually can't be
it can't be decriminalized at the moment
even though
that is what the committee was was
recommending so
um it's interesting to hear councillor's
comments on it and
um just returning to council matheson's
point
he is right that when there is an issue
around
a disclosable bikini interest it is
automatically referred to the police
being a criminal matter
and i am not able to investigate it as
monitoring officer
and also uh councillor matheson alluded
to the fact that quite often
uh the issue is not pursued by the
police and and that quite often is the
case
um particularly when it's quite a low uh
low-level matter
um then then quite often it's not
pursued down the criminal route
um and the complainant then is left with
with really nowhere to go
so um it's interesting to hear those
comments and and i'm happy to
to clarify the the process but as you
say councilman mccord that element won't
be changing in any revised code because
it would require a legislative change
so can i clarify again emily that
actually what we are going to be
discussing and voting upon
or rather or possibly amending is in
fact appendix c
your provided response to the lga
consultation
on this draft model member code of
conduct
that's absolutely right so we're looking
at that that is what we should be
discussing
yeah we're looking at appendix a which
is the proposed revised code
and then the responses um that i've
drafted in appendix c are for the
committee's comments
amendment and and ultimately agreement
so i'd suggest that pages 97 onwards
um your response are probably going to
be because the questions after all
rather explain themselves and that that
this is a point of order because i think
otherwise we're going to be talking
around the houses
that this is actually what we should be
focusing upon
yeah councillor that's the uh bit that
you have the ability to
to influence the the recommendations
from the committee on standard
public life are included because they
provide that important background
context for where the
lga has got its recommendations from
thank you thank you alistair do you have
any other comments on any other part of
this report
on the specific contents of uh appendix
see i do but i confess that uh trying to
find them
at the moment second screen not playing
ball with me
should i come back to you in a while if
you could i would like to find the
sections i had queries about
okay i'll put you on hold ellis uh
councillor mary mccollar and do you have
any comments on this paper
no comments chair thank you uh
councillor dave muller any input no
comments thank you chair
okay thank you are you have you caught
up a bit um
alistair i'm getting there um
i do apologize there's quite a lot to
this uh consultation but there was
there were a couple of i do very much
applaud
um the support given to use of social
media
and the uh difficulties that those
counsellors who use social media
sometimes face
um but also that social media use
should be included within the code of
conduct
i think guidance is essential for for
the proper use of social media
um like any other tool it must be used
responsibly
and i think we're all familiar with
occasions where
uh well-meaning people but perhaps a
little bit too quick on the um
keyboard uh say some pretty outrageous
things
which should not be born and should not
be tolerated
i have a series of rules and i expect
polite
informed discussion but i do not
tolerate anybody in my own group and i
run an active
facebook group um and i make this point
very clearly and
in other groups that i speak on if
people are basically saying things which
are either libelous or slanderous and
people don't appreciate facebook is a
publishing tool
if you publish something on facebook as
a counselor or as an individual
in effect you can be libeling somebody
and i think it's an important point that
we should have protections for
counsellors
we should also make the point very
clearly to the public
that this is the case now the point i
was going to make was there was one
response that
i wasn't happy with i'm sorry emily
and it wasn't a a significant one but it
was
um i do agree this council
to bringing the council into disrepute
which councilor matheson
mentioned um is it clear
um what page is that a hundred and
oh dear it's questions oh no it's just
gone right back to the start
hang on a minute
i do apologize members
it's quite important that we get this
specifically right page 101
question seven um
seven a
yes the left definition acting with
civility no that's the wrong one
this repute is question eight sorry my
apologies page 102.
um this could be better described as
conduct which undermines public trust
and confidence in the local authority
very happy with
that there is not sufficient reference
to the use of social media happy with
that
there was one specific thing which
worried me in that there was a
suggestion
that their and our response should
include
absolutely zero um
amounts for um gifts
uh it's currently 25. um
the committee on public standards
suggested 50
and we're suggesting zero which seems to
me to be moving the opposite direction
the reason i'm quite happy with 25 i've
never even come close to it
but there are occasions when somebody's
kind enough to buy a pint
a definition of zero would actually
preclude that or make it uh declarable
um
if you were going to be strictly
accurate now i know treating is well
established in election law
and is an accepted part of the process
and
nobody counts these things but
fundamentally
in the course of a councillor's business
and duties yes
occasionally people do buy you a pint
and under that
particular viewpoint or a drink or
whatever you know
a sandwich whatever usually of a very
small
minuscule matter and i i'm not happy
that we would um
propose a zero sum for that that's about
the only thing i have to say
emily can i bring you in on that one
please yeah thank you chair
um i'm more than happy to amend that um
as as the committee
wishes but just to give you the
reasoning behind
that suggested response it was just to
reflect the approach that we take with
staff members
which is that gifts and hospitality of
any value must be registered
so it was just reflecting the the
approach that we take with staff
but i'm more than happy to amend the
response as the committee
wishes
robert robert you wish to comment on
this oh yeah just to
support alastair and that i think it is
slightly different role we have and
one of the things where i have 18
different parish councils and
often they invite me for a drink after
the parish council meeting
and i see it as an important part of
kind of maintaining relations with them
to if they offer to buy me a drink
um i'd rather accept their offer than
have to buy them all around
and in many cases it would be insulting
to refuse we're politicians
and we are social animals and part of
our role
is literally to socialize with our
electorate
and and the public in general many of
whom have
as you say it's not just parish councils
um there are a lot of people we talk to
and uh we need that certain amount of
moderate
sensible freedom
okay robert thank you i take your point
i seem to remember that you and i have
gone to a pub and i've fought both times
you did say chair you've been very busy
yes i have been very busy
yes yes um i tend emily to agree
um i i could see the recommendation on
the front was to go up to 50 which i
thought was a bit
high i think nil it just puts you on
tenterhooks all the time
doesn't that if we socialize and or you
go to a meeting with um
parish council of things it does put in
a very difficult position if you think
oh my god i've got to write this down so
i am with robert on that one um
emily unless you can um convince me i'm
committing a crime otherwise
no chair i think that's perfectly
reasonable and i don't hear anybody
suggesting a a very high limit so there
won't be any new cars or anything like
that so i think
that's perfectly reasonable no bicycle
repair
thank you um john john whitehead i'm
i've just spotted you still in the
meeting with um
a raised hand would you like to comment
on anything that you've heard
it was just particularly about emily's
response to question 15 because as i
read that if i go visit a resident and
they say to me would you like a cup of
tea and a biscuit
i'd be having to say well i have to
declare the cup of tea and that's some
how much a hobnob cost
yeah quite right i think that's my point
exactly and roberts as well
that's him some dishonest whatever
yeah i'm sorry john
we can't we can't all be as obstinate as
you obviously are
any other general comments um counselors
before i have one final sort of
whip around you're looking to speak um
john matherson
yeah just just to say that the um look
you know taking the point about what it
is we're discussing and so on in the
dependency there
um now i've found it again um
i think it's alistair is probably making
some some
some very valid points and um i see it's
entirely open to him
or him and colleagues to
um to submit their own views as well
on this yes that is that that option is
is there probably worth exploring
outside one might want to but frankly i
think i think for a council as a whole
we should be providing a coordinated
response that
has been looked at and obviously that's
why the whole council will vote upon it
because if we all do different responses
to all of the what is it 16
questions um it's going to take it make
it very difficult to make a decision i i
believe emily's done an excellent job on
this
i'd like to support the motion as it's
uh presented to us
um and uh propose so
okay aleister i'm taking that as a
proposer
anyone wishes to second i'll be the
second chair chair
yeah thank you dave from mid-suffolk uh
before we leave any final comments on
the
on the complete paper please yes chess
robert robert yes yes far away um
so so just to clarify really because my
my subject my proposal was that that
um with the item on um
[Music]
um council and disrepute
i think emily's put where
sort of only mildly in favor my proposal
was to say we're
not at all in favor of it to talk to
that to not at all
um but uh
do we do i have support for that yeah my
apologies robert i did mark my agenda to
come back to that um
you're saying this is just all part of
the political kick about aren't you
yeah and what is your view on that emily
again chair happy to um adopt
adapt the uh consultation response to
reflect the will of the committee
um i think from uh what council lindsey
is saying that you'd like to
amend question 8 to be not at all rather
than to a
to a small extent yes
i think to be i think to be frank emily
um
we all say things we might slightly
regret and as long as it's polite and if
it's not the apology is given i think
we just um i think it's down to the
average individual to have common sense
on all these matters
so i would um i i would be in favor with
robert on that one i would think
okay well i'm proposing i'm happy to
accept that that should be
changed as robert proposes and we're
taking out the
uh recommendation of all gifts
are we retaining and i would be
proposing that we retain the figure of
25 pounds
yes that has really been agreed rather
than going up to 50. yeah i'm just
wanting to clarify
what is being proposed and therefore
obviously seconded
so those those two points would be the
only alterations we would be making
to the council's response is that
correct that is correct
thank you thank you alistair you're
proposing i've momentarily forgot who
seconded
it was myself for chair dave yes sorry
dave yeah still second thank you yes
well i think we've made a couple of
sensible um
adjustments so i'm well in favor of that
okay mandy if you just like to call the
roll call please
um and it's a joint one this time right
across the board thank you
okay thank you chair so members if you
could reply with four against or
abstain councillor hadingham
four councillor haran yes
four councillor lindsay
four councillor mccrore four
councillor mclaren four councillor
matheson
councillor mueller four thank you chair
that's unanimous
thank you very much mandy i think um
we've dealt with that one just um
perfectly correctly now we're on the
last item
um i'm trying to give everything a good
depth without racing through things too
much
but item 10 moving to page 107 the
forward
plan no jen isn't here emily i think
you're going to present this one is that
correct
muted
okay i think i might be there again now
yeah you are fine
you're very you're very easy to liberate
emily so um
we know what you're saying anyway but
please far away
um i think my machine's on a go slow
this afternoon and it may very well be
the heat um it's certainly very warm in
my uh
dining at my dining table today um yes
tara i'll present the
the report in uh jan's absence although
mandy may wish to to also chip in uh
really chair it's just for the committee
to note
the uh items on the forthcoming work
plan
um and i would just point out at this
point chair that the meeting in
september
contains two standing items
for constitutional updates there are
none proposed at the moment
and in terms of the monitoring officer
report that's simply a statistical
report on the number of
complaints that have been received so
it's not
uh it's not time-bound therefore there
may be a possibility that
the committee may not go ahead in in
september if no other items of business
come forward
so it's a distinct possibility if um
nothing needs doing urgently this
meeting could be abandoned is it
i think cancelled with the agreement of
the chairs is the term
counsellor okay yeah no not a vendor
that i didn't quite mean that
looking at the date um everybody i see
the 28th of september is my annual day
off
and i only get one so um it would be
down to dave to chair anyway but
we'll deal with that as it um comes if
it needs to um go ahead um
dave which here if not we'll agree to
defer
is there any comments from any council
are on the forward
um work plan please um john john
matheson yeah i
of what's on there um
but also a question for some
clarification which emily might be able
to provide
or not and the i felt that the
that we we ought to be
hoping to see our final accounts for
2019-20
um sooner than november
um now we know i mean the the the
government set out this stall
a while back a year and a half something
back now that
um they wanted to accelerate the the
production of the accounts
and as we've heard at the last meeting
again um
ey got into into a very very different
place along with
a lot of its um its colleagues and
competitors
um but really november
you know 31st of march accounts november
um is really we ought to be aiming for
september or october with that i don't
know whether
um melissa or sue are
able to shed any light on that and i've
got a second question after that
okay thank you john i'll call him
melissa i think i know exactly what
you're gonna say melissa but um
please far away to answer john's
question thank you chair and
thanks thank you councilman matheson and
for your question yeah
um the government did extend the
deadline for councils to publish their
uh draft accounts on the website uh
to the 31st of august um and
unfortunately with the covered response
my team have been flat out trying to
respond to things as well as keeping
business as usual running as well which
was really vitally important for the two
councils
so unfortunately we are going to be in
that position where we probably are
going to publish
uh close to the 31st of august what that
does then do is impact on the time frame
that ernst and young were going to be
coming in to audit our accounts
we did have a window of the 13th of july
and they've now redeployed their issues
else their resources elsewhere
so they now won't be starting our audit
until october
there are some things they will be doing
off-site so there's certain
uh things they can be looking at in the
interim
but the main piece of work that they'll
be doing will be starting in october so
unfortunately november is the earliest
we could have that
that audit opinion and the and the
accounts
what about bringing the the um bringing
the draft accounts to the september
meeting
if you're you're going for the 31st of
august for
subs to give it to the auditors um so we
we could have a look at the
in draft see how things are looking
because i mean this is going to be quite
critical stuff is it going to cabinet or
anywhere else
no no it doesn't go to cabinet it just
comes to join audience standards
committee
i mean it's certainly something i can i
can discuss with catherine
yes please yeah can i just raise the
point there though
we have after all just gone through two
meetings in about a fortnight
um we've looked at those uh accounts
this will only be three months after the
last time we examined any accounts and
i'm not sure i see a great deal of point
in looking at draft um
a draft audit statement is something of
a contradiction in terms in my opinion
um so i'm not sure there's a great deal
of value in that
plus say this committee would normally
meet once a quarter
we just obviously had a bit of catch up
because of kobit 19.
um if september doesn't happen we've
still got
looking at the schedule and i'm just
thinking of councillor's time because
i'm aware that that
these have not been short meetings
november seems perfectly reasonable
um given the context of this committee
and how it has operated in the past
i just don't want to see us overloading
ourselves with
repetition of the same ground and i
think there's a danger of that
we're also meeting in january with a
very full agenda
um and i would say i would suggest and
then again in march
so in fact if anything we're
accelerating um
our work program above and beyond what
would normally be the case
yeah i think i have to say committee i
do agree with that um we do respect you
john matheson um
the accounts are the accounts i don't
see any point in looking at
draft accounts that might be altered
later so i would not um
support cnn for the sake of it um
dave you were waving a while yeah yeah i
totally agree with um aleister and also
yourself rin
i i would not recommend looking at the
draft account to say they could well be
amended
and i would literally like to see the
final accounts once they are actually
ready thank you thank you
melissa can you just sort of reassure us
well also for the reason it's just tough
time i presume isn't it and you're
obviously under a fair bit of pressure
absolutely yeah um if i could just
mention the other thing we did want to
work on as well before coming back in
november and i think it was raised at
the last meeting was um an explanation
around uh how sifko
and the holding accounts feed into our
accounts so obviously we'd like to do a
little bit of work to have that
ready as well so i think if we come back
in september i think we might not have
enough time to to pull all that together
and we want to give you
a real thorough understanding of how
those numbers feature in our accounts as
well so
it would be helpful to have a little bit
more time to pull that together so it's
it's you know understandable and gives
you what you need
okay thank you melissa just to reassure
everybody um
dave and myself as co-chairs we are in
constant
touch with the lead officers and if
they're struggling they do tell us so um
there is quite a bit going on so please
be reassured that um
everybody is doing the best and i don't
want to cane the staff who obviously i'm
putting in extra hours and some have
been on other duties anyway due to the
um
position we're in at the moment um dave
dave miller would you just like to um
clarify that please yes i i totally
agree with with that bring and i'd like
to thank the officers for their hard
work
um in this in these difficult times so
thank you
yeah looking at the agendas ahead to
come i think we're going to have a lot
uh to come on and it is going to be
accelerating so you know let's just all
breathe slowly for a while take a bit of
time and do it properly
um john john madison melissa um
certainly began to address the exact
exact question that i wanted to ask
really
which was in terms of the um the
accounts and
and audits of our subsidiary companies
um
so are they going to feature on the
forward plan
or are they they're going to be tucked
up together with
how are you thinking of doing that
melissa
yes melissa this is not going to be
allowed to rest so maybe
maybe you can um assure us on this one
please no i think there should be an
open debate on this
and um i take it you would welcome that
as well
yes certainly i mean anything we can
help to you know clarify
the picture and make things clear on how
you know the audio opinions on the sifko
and the company's accounts differ to you
know with the work that
um ernest young do we certainly would
like to have that dialogue to make it
you know as clear as possible absolutely
because i think when you look at the
accounts it's
not that easy to see the numbers in
there um so anything we can do obviously
we've got the statutory duty to present
them in the way they do but we can do
extra to
to give you that that clearer picture as
well so we'd certainly like to have that
conversation about what you would need
to to see that picture
thank you melissa and to everybody you
know it's important that we move along
steadily especially with what we're all
facing
and as long as it in a straight line
without
too many deviations um we should all
stick together on this one
um dave you still got your hand up no
sorry
apologies that's all right don't worry
we're all we're all a bit trigger-happy
um so we'll see each other looks like
i'm 30th of november
and possibly not the um 28th of
september
um anything else that anybody wishes to
raise to this point
regarding a future meeting
no well i thank you all very very much
for your attendance and
um i will see you at the next meeting um
whenever that might be if we miss one
um it will be dave's chair to turn to
chair that one i would think
if we do talk to each other and we if
one is away we'll always substitute for
the other and um
keep the score roughly even and thank
you to all the officers um
um for all your time and i'm sorry the
circumstances of the heat at the moment
but it will cool down tomorrow right
here
the meeting is officially closed thank
you very much everybody thank you
you